welcome to this video playing maradona
sighs learn all on Islands how the sky
had some other flick earlier okay
Spanish opening or rule dope-ass let's
see what line we we get playing with d3
for a change I don't I don't know that
too well but just to to try something
something different they often play
Knight c3 here nowadays intending
amongst others nitey to 2 g-3 bishop
your phone interesting
okay wait if i play h3 is going to take
a plane I deform and this is a bit
uncomfortable maybe 93 wasn't a good
move after after all yeah yeah it's okay
probably need to cover deform not very
quickly played okay take it don't don't
really have a big epic choice iam yeah
where'd you go don't think night d 5 or
so oh why not come on shouldn't be bad I
can and I can play 83 and G ing form if
everything else fails I just takes it
hmm interesting the same I really didn't
expect the cell should be you know maybe
a little bit a little bit of an
advantage for white trying to
keep a six-under tech by playing Bishop
c4 yeah this should be better for why
this position the bishop p.m. on c4 is
just a lot better than the bishop on f6
but how to how to continue preparing f4
is certainly an idea it's let's do that
have form with one idea being to to push
with e five trying to increase the
pressure on f7 the c-4 Bishop has the
nice dual function of attacking a six
and young making black spend some some
peace like the rook to protected and it
attacks also have seven this is the the
nice thing about it on the other hand a
five is also needing some protection
thinking about g4g 5 even or queen to d5
yeah interesting not sure I don't really
want to exchange Queens
yeah it's looking play g5 and g6 Queen
Queen g5 oh it's just a check it's not
two not a mate I'll take it
mm-hmm okay check but now and one
promise this is a queen is so it's not
it's a bit off site at the moment I
wonder if I should do yeah probably
assure to just get get this Queen over
2g form this porn on f7 should really be
enough to to win an end game as it is
always protected by it by the bishop so
Queen g5 to squeegee form
for Queen h4 Queen g4 and if he does not
exchange Queens himself I'm going to
play rook f5 and so on just attacking
what Queen h5 is an immediate made if he
allows it the porn is just a big problem
yeah not moving check ok let's go him
check yeah it's trying to defend this
end game let's see what's the the best
way to go maybe prepare ruin doubling
doubling on them on the edge phone
okay yeah well a six is always hanging
at the end this should turn should be a
big big factor this is this one h eight
yeah look h eight i can take and then
take a six
should I could have played g5 actually
cutting off the king yeah probably so
that rook age 30 gauge haven't as an
actual checkmate threat yeah that's good
black resign this is over Brooke h3 is
is threatening a deadly checkmate I was
somewhat somewhat strange he very
quickly got into the service is bad
position and I was a bit surprised about
many quick decisions yeah this this
looks excellent for white really he must
avoid that I'm not not so sure how
exactly maybe here it's time for some
prophylactic moves yeah maybe this is a
good day good one maybe king a queen to
d7 so that a 4 is not immediately
possible I could prepare that with
Bishop effect to be three and then a
four but this discuss time therefore I
can just take it at the moment this is
probably an improvement and Ti yeah well
maybe maybe you should consider to take
it well here I also have this move
trapping the rook something like this
could win the exchange possible yeah
well this is this is a terrible position
I mean just a very one-sided affair
Queen trade is also also okay and this
is just just winning yeah just just a
very quick win and um maybe here iff our
queen e 6 is the best mover according to
comp okay I was thinking that I could
also go rook f3 for example
scanning like that Oh a kept this can
easily backfire yep yeah well Queenie
six is better at simply using the Queen
to to defend and this just killed skills
at offering him he proceeds to exchange
and check this is over g5 maybe a small
precise but it's it's it's a win
nevertheless okay thanks for watching